he goes to push and then I'm gonna find
my angle but this drills for a bouquet
okay so right now you're balancing
yourself I find my feet sort of I arms
and now rather than leaning into me
finding my feet through your arms you're
not quite there just being tight find my
feet go ahead and lean
[Music]
and you find my feet so you're not
balancing the sand to it
[Music]
let's get more children
find my feet you're not balanced
there are three points of contact
[Music]
trying to see Kimmy truck if I go into
this this pose here the leg is the leg
and the weight of the senator property
words the leg spins around me that's why
we roll like that right you'll have to
keep making micro adjustments if you
just hang out here that links gonna spin
around you and eventually you're lying
and grab me able to fall out of your
base of support so when we go boom you
can see that if I let go and you you're
going to eventually lose your balance
once you hit that 90 parallel to the
crown but what happens is when I have
contact with them I have this huge base
of support and that leg can now be
stable stabilized and that's different
from fighting his feet by falling on him
I'm just connecting through here and you
can see I can hang out here all day long
so try not to lean on him you are
pressing into his feet and if that's the
most you could feel his feet then go
ahead and lean but as you we're going on
with reps try to just have the
connection of energy through whatever
you're touching okay he's he's part my
feet even on this even on this
get your leg on fire push into me there
you go
yeah
[Music]
let's find my feet even even as your
head goes down don't lose my feet that's
it even as your head goes down don't
lose my seat yes come on find my feet
there you go
okay so this same feeling I push okay
and you find my feet by my foot that one
foot that's it
[Music]
goodbye my foot so you have three points
of contact there you go
find this way
come on do so find the foot
okay trying to switch it you're still
doing the same thing but now you're not
yet okay try to push right look look
look where I am
oriented where would you say where's my
spine nose lining oriented towards what
tortoises yeah towards the foot towards
the center you guys are all doing Aikido
techniques see that because you're
trying to get his head so you won't you
go like this you're not going to feel
that
see where I eat the connection here
[Music]
you guys are all over here
to preach he feels my feet to project I
can do a weight shift or to seek yashi
[Music]
connection here and there
wait finding his feet Oh see I'm on
the back leg
go wait you see where I am I hope
you're here trying to turn this when you
move in everything stays locked so don't
have your arms go in it up keep the
connection just move it forward let's
try
so he goes right if you can't again you
can see where my orientation is it's not
trying to turn him he's he's finding my
feet please please okay here you're not
using so I find his foot too
it's you're gonna feel a sense of
stability just like you were when you
reboot game right the stability is going
to come from I'm just gonna speak almost
metaphorically through friction through
the absence of movement through weight
and mass this hand is not into me okay
and so I want that's what I want and I'm
gonna go in I'm gonna sink into that not
go around it look where are oriented and
I could feel that so move the right way
load the foot shift
[Music]
okay into that you can think of you can
think of the foot I'm gonna try to move
his foot okay I try to move his foot
[Music]
so I go round it here and you know and
we're not doing this either we're trying
to understand the energy so it's hard to
know what to do when you don't know what
if you're feeling for okay so we're just
trying to do different things to imagine
so you're feeling gets right so I'm
going to go through that foot
[Music]
no mistakes is you're out here you're
you're doing a delusion alarm control so
IQ know is cause she's knocking it into
distance so when I do cushion I get you
see how we have to fit together
our centers have to work around each
other so when we do this drill and I'm
all like this this is this is part of
opponent that's here but he's over here
you guys so kokyu nage might look the
same especially as we're going as record
a little quicker but we got a look
closer you're going to actually know his
trajectory is different mechanisms and
his interrelated articulation point is
different okay so you're still too far
out here
yeah that's why you're letting his arm
just go by so you can get in there okay
you're just pushing dog in a distance so
your Senators still have to aim at each
other you gotta push okay don't worry
about me
go push that's it then the second error
is again it's just it's too external so
we have we got all the connection we
want and then you're just like I'll step
past isthmus SCO fault is your
displacement what displacement is not
projection okay so if you watch when i
displace like I've closed the cap
projection we don't this my here doesn't
change
and that makes it weapon savvy so boom
okay how do I do that
you gotta lock up just like you were
going to punch somebody okay so I'm
locked out my Center and this is the
writer of the horse and the horse moves
in and boom here horse rider
[Music]
force writer now as you go and you now
use your arms to do that now okay that
was the projection but not one stemming
from the body the lower half of the body
right so don't do that oh my arms stay
where they are and I just moved the
horse if you if you do move your arms
you can do a tiny little pump because
most of you can't will start disengaging
once they fall okay so they'll be like
up okay so it's not it's not magic is he
pushes right he's his line of gravity
center of gravity base of support
mechanism is now connected to me do you
get do you got it that's the first drill
can you get your foot up okay
that's the first stroke in the second
drill I disobey me for that myself I am
getting his line to ground where the
center of every bases afford and he
stood
to be dependent on me so that's why when
I go like this then that's not happening
and you get all the gymnastic Bluefish
you catch up right and then do their
flip so I get kid that's it he's now
he's on me you get that okay now all I'm
doing is taking that center of gravity
and projecting it so the line you drive
you fall down on the base of support how
quick if you go slow right you see
you'll you're just seeing the balance
breaking myth mechanics but if you do it
percussively right boom then this life
you either you know you move a rock or
you throw a rock you understand it you
do ballistic or fixated so
you guys got it okay so it's not magic
go it's difficult to know what to do
because you're not there's no source
material like I'm trying to explain to
you what red is but you've never seen a
color before right how am I going to
explain that to you and we have a lot of
source material that makes us go from
one meaning to the other meaning
so and every time you don't have the
source material then you provide the
source material and it comes from a
place of ignorance so it's probably not
going to be it okay so none of this is
really quite accurate this is just in
Piatt where I'm trying to get your body
to do a certain thing but every drill
that you milk is now that apply to
actually worked against you those that
that tailored lesson to try to get you
to another level not necessarily using
the most accurate of information if you
milk it now that this is just deception
and now become self-deception okay so
that's what we're trying to do so Lea
and then Sean come out of it and you
will be better off if you stick to all
the other basics that we don't cover in
this lesson
because when you don't then you're
milking you're gonna milk this row so
you will be done yet so already there's
a bracing angle can you see it and she's
pushing on him right and you have this
elbow tilted here okay now what does
that elbow doing for you you're trying
to do something with it what keep him
out okay so he's keep that elbow there
please move and let's apply force and
see if it actually works
you see that let's back in
[Music]
okay wait so you you have this arch get
it up and get mid-foot not heal and
you're a little bit too Ike you know
tightrope for me hi okay get your deep
where your where your hips are okay okay
this arm you're doing this same thing is
you're trying to hook hip and so you
have warp in do you see that and so this
is bicep you can feel it
so extend right and relax you don't need
a hook to have contact okay then release
crown on your head
same thing here you're hooking you don't
need a hook
now the difficult part there is a right
way of moving so you go oh
so what you do yeah you're talking to
wind up okay came inside and forward of
the toes and the arched gate well all
your Energy's going out okay so get your
here boom hey he's I'm around it right
even this hand no don't look there just
where it is it's gonna be just fine
right you see my feet not here here this
doe come back his energy is
disconnecting or you go again and he's
gonna fill it so here right just for
your eye so you can milk all of it you
can milk every single micro drill you
can know means you can cheat you guys so
how low what I do don't violate all the
other lessons that you've been working
on okay let's go we're trying to use
this micro drilling to get them really
not how you throw it's not how your body
we just want that heal okay so when he
goes to push you see I make that shape
that we always want you see that
so he's pushing push push TC push and I
yield and there's the shape that I want
you see this that his head is here and I
pattern you got it my arm he pushes and
my body moves wherever I need to move in
order to keep and allow my arms to do
what they need to do to get that shape
you see that and I will take this in to
cookie not yet because what we have here
now is you're going like this and you're
going like that that's the tough one to
do with there's more momentum momentum
[Music]
so what are you notice me what do you
thinks gonna happen to his center of
gravity when you increase the effort
it's getting a farther gonna go faster
how about its angle farther we're
backwards forward and ER forward right
how do you remotes test it go halfway
[Music]
that would be like me TV ad okay and now
let's have them go full speed run yeah
[Music]
it's gonna go forward so your trajectory
point in terms of manipulating the
center of gravity line drive you can't
be at that foot angle where it was when
we were going slow just like you have to
lead the shot the guy who's running the
deers Ronnie you got to leave the shot
you can't go where he is you're throwing
the football you got to leave the
receiver you understand
so the same thing here the feeling is
the same push well the feeling is saying
but the angle the vector is slightly
different you can see it's more forward
right not here he's pushing push right
[Music]